[Music]
morning all it's emerged that the uk is
in talks with the taliban in an attempt
to ensure safe passage for people over
the afghanistan border when that move
comes as the foreign secretary faces a
big day with mps preparing to question
him on the taliban takeover we'll be
bringing you that live at two o'clock
here on sky news uh but before all that
here are the morning's main developments
uk officials and the taliban are in
talks in doha
over how to secure safe passage out of
afghanistan for british nationals and
afghan allies meanwhile the home office
has confirmed that afghans who worked
with the british government and military
who now hope to rebuild their lives in
the uk will be given indefinite leave to
remain apple in the united states
president joe biden addressed the nation
last night
once again defending his decision to
withdraw troops from afghanistan our u.s
correspondent mark stone has our first
report
on the tarmac at kabul airport images
which so clearly define an american
defeat
wearing american kit most with american
weapons
this is america's enemy now back in
charge
this is a man who for 10 years has been
a faceless voice of the taliban in
hiding a man who denies bin laden was
responsible for 9 11.
now leading the celebrations for what
they are calling afghanistan's
independence day
[Applause]
across the sprawling airport our cameras
filmed what's left of military equipment
abandoned when the afghan government
collapsed
the americans had hastily intentionally
damaged what they could as they withdrew
in washington the president appeared to
declare a mission accomplished he was
though claiming a success in achieving a
retreat
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats and
intelligence professionals it was again
a defense of his decision to bring this
war to an end
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
for terrorists there was this warning
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
the president can of course for now
successfully claim that this so-called
forever war is over but it is the legacy
which will follow him the impact it's
had on allies the chaos has cost them
politically the message it sends to
russia and china about american
priorities and then of course the
all-important reaction of the american
people they wanted this war finished but
it's the way it was brought to an end
people and equipment left behind and the
enemy and terrorists emboldened
south of kabul in the city of cost
taliban supporters with coffins
representing the west a message from
them but may be a reflection too of a
shift in western foreign policy no
longer able or willing to intervene mark
stone sky news in washington
i will join us now once again on the
program the home office minister
victoria atkins minister good to see you
again do hope you're well and by golly
you've got a busy day don't you uh
launching operation warm welcome the way
by which we're going to well look after
uh those afghans that looked after us in
afghanistan just tell us a bit more
about it
very much so well over the last two
weeks alone we've evacuated some 15 000
people to our country and of course
since april uh we've evacuated more
people who have done right by us they're
the people who on the ground over the
last 20 years have been working with our
soldiers helping to protect them helping
to translate helping to make our
embassies and other areas work and so
the prime minister's commitment is
absolutely clear to this um they have
done right by us we want to do right by
them and so today i'm delighted that
we're launching operation warm welcome
to give a warm welcome to everyone who
has landed on our shores in recent weeks
but in the longer term as well
and make sure that with us with our help
they can build bright futures in our
country
of course the the the option to have
indefinite leave to romania will be
grabbing everyone's attention but
there's also a lot more assistance for
those that have arrived under rare up as
well
very much so so um we uh have to
today announced uh indefinite leave to
remain as you say which is important
because it means that they have for
example rights to work and so many of
the people that we've been watching our
television screens over the last few
days uh have expressed the wish to give
back to the uk
once they're settled here with their
families but we also want people to
integrate you know this has got to be
fair to the british people as well as to
our new afghan neighbors and friends and
so we are
setting out plans to help
adults and those who don't speak english
to learn our language so that they can
contribute fully to our society and also
importantly educating those children
their children have witnessed the most
traumatic scenes in recent weeks and we
want to get those children
into our schooling system with the right
help the right support so that again
we're building positive futures for them
and so we're announcing 12 million
pounds to support that education effort
we're also conscious of course as well
that there will be some very severe
medical needs again some of the trauma
that people will have witnessed and
experienced we must confront we must
deal with and so we're announcing a
further three million pounds to help
with the health care needs of people
and in addition of course everybody
needs homes and so there's a long-term
piece of work to ensure that we're able
to provide homes for people who have
come to our country
administers all of this applies to those
who who have come here and will continue
to come here under the afghan relocation
and assistance program what about those
who will be coming here under under the
resettlement scheme will they be
afforded indefinitely to remain as well
well we're very much working on this
scheme at the moment um you'll
appreciate that this is uh it's a huge
task ahead of us um and we want to get
it right and look we've done this before
because we've done this with the syrian
resettlement programme
and that has been widely been judged to
be a success and so we want to take the
very best parts of that scheme to build
this new scheme to help those who are
vulnerable within afghanistan those who
may have espoused western values who may
have stood up for women's rights for
example as well as but just but just
sorry it's interesting because we've got
finite time but just in terms of we have
already subject we've already suggested
that we will be taking 5 000 people
separately under the resettlement scheme
this year alone
when they get here
has it been decided yet whether or not
they will be allowed to be granted
indefinitely to remain
as i say please don't read anything into
it other than we're just working on it
at the moment as i said this is a very
very um fast-paced very very large task
and i've got 10 000 people um staying in
quarantine hotels today for example
we've got to make plans for the bridging
accommodation that they move into once
they're released from quarantine so um
these decisions will be made in due
course but i very much hope that from
the announcements today
uh
british people but also importantly uh
afghans who have moved to our country
very recently really get the sense of
how warm and welcoming the government
wants to be towards them and indeed this
is reflected in the response of british
people themselves uh we've seen over the
last few days how generous people have
been
i know barbara for example people turned
up to the hotel where afghans are
staying with toys with nappies with
clothes
trying to do their best to to help and i
we want to very much take advantage and
seize every opportunity of kindness that
people are able to offer and
we're developing at the moment a portal
that people will be able to log on to to
uh register how they can hope to help
afghan friends moving into their area in
indeed but but of course you know time
is in essence of the essence but for
those who remain in afghanistan at the
moment we know from speaking to the
foreign secretary yesterday that at
least several hundred low hundreds but
several hundred you know british
nationals remain in afghanistan there
are also thousands of others who may
have been able to qualify for anap or
may have been able to qualify for the
resettlement scheme and at the moment
the advice seems to be
get to the border get over the border
what happens after that point how can
they then make their way to the united
kingdom or indeed to is there a
processing center we've heard that
talked about a number of times
yeah so um the foreign office as the
foreign secretary set out yesterday the
foreign office are in uh intense
discussions with third countries in the
region
because we want to make sure that if
people are coming to the border which
they will be um that those third
countries are able to deal fairly and
efficiently with those people and so
we're very much in discussions with them
of course part of this
is um ensuring that the taliban
do what the un security council
resolution requires them to do namely to
offer safe passage to people who are
rightly traveling to the borders to um
uh to seek sanctuary and what do we do
what how far are we prepared to go with
the taliban if they renege on promises
that they they have already made in
terms of secret passage
so simon gass uh has it's been announced
overnight simon gas the prime minister's
representative on afghan uh resettlement
is um very special envoy is very much uh
there in doha at the moment discussing
with senior taliban figures on the
future and i i don't want to in any way
uh impinge on those discussions
but the international community is
watching very closely what the taliban
is doing and will do over the next uh
weeks and months
and uh the foreign secretary and others
have been clear that we will use every
lever at our disposal diplomatic and
otherwise to ensure that the taliban
lives up to the resolution that was
passed by the security council
as mentioned before of course those
relocating here under arab they have the
afghan relocation program i mean they
they are people who have assisted us you
know in our fight in in afghanistan and
and their families and and people will
not begrudge them
being helped when they reach this
country but but do you not accept
that you have in essence now created
another tier another class perhaps
within our immigration and asylum system
well i don't think anyone watching the
scenes that we've seen over the last
couple of weeks could have failed to
have been moved by the
terror the desperation the anguish the
fear that people
were experiencing
not just outside the gates of the
airport but also of course across the
country and so i very much and i have
complete confidence that uh as you say
uh british people will understand that
and will want to respond and insurance
but do you do you accept that they are
going to be treated differently by the
immigration and asylum program to anyone
else
well we have already the model for this
with the syrian resettlement scheme uh
as i say you know that was set up in
2015 um that we went to great efforts to
ensure that accommodation and other
services were already set up in advance
of syrians being lifted from refugee
camps to come to this country for safe
sanctuary um
these circumstances are obviously pretty
different not least because we've had to
evacuate people at such uh fast pace
into the uk
but i would hope that given the um
the effort the work that
these translators these security guards
these
afghan army
members have
done for us over the last two decades
the british soldiers they will have
worked with the lives potentially some
of them will have saved i'm very much
hoping that we'll be able to as i say do
right by them just as they did right by
us
just very specifically on on the
re-housing of those who are coming here
do we do we really have the capacity to
re-home what 20 000 plus
afghans over the next five years when we
heard from local government association
chairman james jameson earlier you know
the nature of the refugees we're seeing
significantly larger families housing
stock as you well know is at a premium
in every part of the country
particularly when we get to the larger
sciences and work we're kind of giving 5
million top up payment to local
authorities that's not going to quite
cover it alone is it
look i want to be straight with people
this is a very very difficult challenge
and we are very very aware that of the
pressures on the housing market and
housing
lists already that is why
we have announced this as you say top-up
fund to help councils find larger
properties for
afghan families but it comes back to
integration again
this policy will succeed if we welcome
and we integrate people into our
societies and we get them settled into
accommodation help their children get
into schools get them registered at gps
and so on and then they can begin to
pay
back into our society and i've heard
some wonderful stories over the last few
days you know people who have fought
with the british army have translated
for the british army determined
when they can to if they're allowed to
join the british army uh others who very
much want to
study so that they can continue their
medical careers and so on there have
been some really really inspirational um
stories that we've heard
i just want to squeeze in just a just a
kind of a final comment of course
afghans fleeing the country will be
trying to get to different parts of the
world for safety by a variety of means
we understand of course from this
government that in future you are
seeking
to deny asylum to people who arrive in
the uk having passed through other safe
countries it would seem that at some
point in the not too distant future
there will be hundreds if not thousands
of afghans who have made their way
through safe countries coming to the uk
and trying to claim asylum will we truly
deny them asylum at that point because
they have passed through safe countries
we are absolutely determined to crack
down on the illegal people trafficking
gangs that we see exploiting the channel
exploiting people um for profit it is
incredibly dangerous for people to make
these journeys i mean i my previous
career i used to prosecute criminals for
a living and and uh some of the cr the
migration cases i saw at the time were
truly truly horrific and so we want to
stop that
and we've got to send this very clear
message out to the people traffickers
that if they do this if they're caught
then uh they will be dealt with in our
justice system
and when you just to underline how
dangerous it is i mean very recently
someone sadly died in the channel trying
to make their journey across so this is
why
as part of this package we're saying
look we won't put up with illegal
immigration but please please use safe
and legal routes and that's why the
afghan resettlement scheme is so
important and taking you know what
little time we've taken to set it up
properly is vital because we want to
help people
who you know should come to this country
want to help them come here legally and
safely as indeed we did with the syrian
resettlement scheme
victoria atkins good to see you again
thanks very much for joining us thank
you
well as we've been hearing the
government says the uk is talking with
the taliban trying to ensure the britons
can safely leave afghanistan let's head
to doha and our correspondent sally
lockwoods and sally as we understand it
as well as we know well from you from
your interview with the spokesman before
there is a taliban presence in doha and
it's there that some of these meetings
have been taking place
yeah that's right qatar was always
destined to be a key player in the
chapter of what happens next after
military withdrawal and certainly the us
the uk they have moved their diplomatic
staff
here and they are talking to the taliban
the taliban now now face the harsh
reality of what it's going to be like
trying to govern afghanistan and the
internet international community now
face the very real reality that they
need to have talks with the taliban in
terms of you know ensuring british
interests and the safety of the afghan
people going forward
uh now the prime minister's uh special
representative on afghan transitions
says simon gas a senior figure in the
intelligence community he is in doha at
the moment and has held talks with
senior taliban leaders now
sky news has been told that uh one of
the main things that he's trying to
ensure at the moment is safe passage for
any remaining british nationals
and afghans who worked for the british
military to leave the country and we
understand that crisis uh staff are
being sent to neighbouring countries
such as pakistan in the next 48 hours to
try and ensure safe passage across land
borders for those
british nationals and former british
employees who are afghans
safe passage across land borders in
order to try and get out of the country
but certainly that is something that the
international community and diplomats
now will have to deal with is that
they're going to have to sit and talk to
the taliban in terms of what happens
next because of course they wield the
power
now in afghanistan they control the
airport at kabul which remains closed so
for now getting anyone out will have to
be over land border
sally many thanks indeed
i will dominic raab will be answering
questions on the government's
afghanistan policy in front of the
foreign affairs committee that's at two
o'clock this afternoon we'll bring you
full coverage of that here on the
channel
i have it still to come on this program
the uk government is holding talks with
the taliban
to ensure that britain's can safely
leave afghanistan at far past eight
we'll be getting the thoughts of the
former chief of the secret intelligence
service sir john sawyer
the chinese government has introduced
tough new limits on how long under-18s
can spend playing video games just a
little later i'll be asking one
technology journalist
if it's a good idea
at half past nine i'll be talking to
former professional footballer ashley
kane who's aiming to cycle 1 000 miles
to raise money for a charity set up in
the memory of his eight-month-old baby
i know a new drug to lower cholesterol
hailed as a potential game changer is to
be offered to hundreds of thousands of
people on the nhs
uh the drug named includeram could
prevent tens of thousands of premature
deaths and more than 50 000 heart
attacks
more than two in five people have high
cholesterol
six and a half million adults are taking
lipid lowering drugs such as statins
it's predicted that this new drug could
save as many as 30 000 lives over the
next decade
parts of louisiana could be without
electricity for weeks
in the wake of hurricane ida well the
worst affected areas are new orleans
southern mississippi and baton rouge our
u.s correspondent greg milan reports
from new orleans where food kitchens
have been set up and people are queuing
to get petrol
there is a slow motion crisis unfolding
in new orleans where they survived the
impact of ida but now face weeks living
like this
in the sweltering summer humidity queues
growing at one of the few places in town
with petrol
and the warning it could be a month
before the electricity is back on our
thoughts go out to everybody that has
been impacted by this devastating storm
for now they rely on the wind-up radio
the generosity of those with generators
and that famous new orleans resilience
it's a big mess and most people have
left town
i think part of that is due to the power
outages there's power things i mean it
seems
crazy that it could be weeks
what do you think about that
i think i wonder if i should leave
[Laughter]
but i think they're people who are a lot
worse off than than than we are
but ida left at least one horrifying
story behind a man apparently killed by
an alligator in front of his wife
outside his flooded home in this
neighborhood it wasn't the danger from
ida they'd expected here it really
freaked us out because it's only one
road over from ours it's like on the
next road over and so
just the thought of an alligator being
loose out here
terrifies me i ain't gonna lie to
the thought of that what happened to
that poor guy is really really sad
though you know i mean
i can't even imagine what he or she went
through
moore died when part of a road gave way
in torrential rain in mississippi across
the region officials expect the number
to rise
most of the hospitals do have emergency
power but already swamped with a surge
in covid cases before ida they're
worried of a further spread in the chaos
for many even the basics of a hot meal
are welcome and frustrations growing
because they thought new orleans had
learned lessons from hurricanes past
what did einstein say keep doing the
same thing and expecting the different
results is insanity and that's what we
have we pay electricity bill that's
upwards of 400 a month and now we don't
have electricity i was born and raised
in new orleans and new orleans people
are resilient
and we're going to get through this
we always do so just just hang tight
guard is on our side
this is a city that's had more than its
share of adversity greg milam sky news
new orleans
now let's take a quick look at the
impact of climate change on the planet
uh here's the graphic the top line
shows exactly how the uk's power is
being produced at 45 of it's still from
fossil fuels and you can also see just
how much warmer the earth is now than in
1880
when modern record keeping began then
the next figure that's uh how long it is
that scientists take it believe it will
take to reach the plus 1.5 degrees
celsius figure
seen by many as a point of no return for
the planets and finally a huge and
frankly frightening statistic the total
amount of
co2 emissions in millions of tons
a couple of other stories now and a
british man charged with conspiring to
torture and behead american and european
hostages in syria is set to plead guilty
in a court case in the united states
alexander cote was a member of an
islamic state cell known as the beatles
which reportedly executed prisoners in
syria coty and another man el-shafi
al-shaikh were brought to the u.s last
year
it's not yet clear which charges coty
will admit to have the hearing on
thursday
the metropolitan police has been warned
that it could be putting children in
danger over its handling of online child
sex abuse investigations
inspectors found that some officers
delayed alerting social services that a
child was living with a suspect
so as not to jeopardize the
investigation
uh well let's run you through the latest
coronavirus data for the uk it shows
that there have been 32
181 new cases in the latest 24-hour
period a further 50 people have died
after contracting covet which takes the
total number of people who died within
28 days of a positive test i should say
to 132
535.
well another 19
643 first doses of a covered vaccine
have been given 66
648 received their second so in total
more than 42.7 million people have now
had both doses of a coronavirus vaccine
uh more than that of course throughout
the day but time for us to have a quick
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
when the high pressure continues to keep
the weather very quiet until the weekend
what i'm afraid it's going to become
rather more unsettled
this morning many places dry but the
cloud is extensive the clearest skies
are in the northwest where it is quite
chilly but early mist and fog will give
way to sunny spells any light showers
through central and eastern parts will
die away through the morning cloud will
thin and break to give a few sunny
spells through southernmost counties but
the best of the sunshine will be in over
northern ireland along with western and
central scotland temperatures there
might just reach 23 or 24 celsius that's
75
fahrenheit it'll be cooler elsewhere
under the cloud and
particularly in the south and east where
it will be breezy
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now let me tell you the final chapter in
the story of a triceratops named
big john take a look at this he is
apparently the largest triceratops ever
to be discovered by paleontologists and
now his fossilized remains are about to
be auctioned off
so you could have the chance to own a
piece of them it's thought that they
could fetch up to 1.5 million euros when
sold in paris a little later big john
roamed the land in south dakota more
than 66 million years ago the first
bones in fact were unearthed in 2014.
during the dig they discovered around 60
of the dinosaur skeleton including a
near-complete skull and if you're
wondering how the dino got his name he
was called big john
in honor of the owner of the land where
more than 200 of his bones were found i
don't have a million and a half euros if
i did i think i'd be tempted uh anyway
coming up after the break at uk
officials well they are meeting with the
taliban in doha to try and secure safe
passage for british nationals and afghan
allies we'll be speaking to the former
foreign minister in pakistan
[Music]
i'm uh i'm a disney prince well not not
quite but yeah i'm a love interest in it
in a disney stage show it's incredible
um the film resonated with so many
people and we
get to bring that to london audiences um
across the world uh you know once
now that the west end is has reopened
we're gonna have audiences
coming back in and we had our first
preview with a thousand eight hundred
people
um
listening to samantha barks and
stephanie mckeon um and the hearing let
it go and the audience reaction to that
was just was was phenomenal it's
obviously it's been a really tough time
for lots of people um i think for a lot
of actors
and for you know for our whole industry
we were sort of the first ones in and uh
you know the first ones out and the last
ones back in
so to have that for the first time
um you know in forever and have everyone
uh back on stage performing to an
audience just felt electric um the story
that we get to tell is a disney story
and hearing though that the music of the
lopez is um with a live orchestra uh
sharing that moment there genuinely
there there is magic that happens that
there's a royal jury lane um that
is something that only disney can do and
so
when the breadth of the audience is
collectively taken away you hear nearly
2 000 people gasp uh it's it's genuinely
special um so i'm really looking forward
to sharing that with more people
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
english in future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife country
[Music]
welcome back uh we've learned that the
uk is in talks with taliban officials in
doha to ensure that more britons and
afghan allies can safely leave
afghanistan well in the last few minutes
the home office minister victoria atkins
warned that the taliban must stick to
those promises that they've made to the
british government
the international community
is watching very closely what the
taliban is doing and will do over the
next uh weeks and months
and uh foreign secretary and others have
been clear that we will use every lever
at our disposal diplomatic and otherwise
to ensure that the taliban lives up to
the resolution that was passed by the
security council
our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen is here morning tc and of course
the bulk of the our conversation with
the homeless minister this morning was
about operation warm welcome the way in
which uh those afghans and their
families those that helped us in
afghanistan who qualified under the
relocation program how they will be
dealt with at this end but it also
raises a number of other questions
though doesn't it that's right so this
operation warm welcome which the home
office has announced today means that of
those 8 000 afghans who've been
airlifted to the uk mostly over the last
couple of weeks they will be able to
have indefinite leave to remain in the
uk straight away that means that they
have unrestricted rights to work there
will be money put into helping them
integrate as victoria atkins put it with
school places language courses and other
support that they may need and that
opens the door to them applying for
british citizenship if they've lived
here for five years now that is very
different from afghans who may
have fled the country already made their
way overland and accessed the uk that
way she made clear that the government
is still very committed to cracking down
on illegal immigration and people
trafficking and so people who come in
through those routes will not be given a
warm welcome if you like they will be
treated um through the full force of the
law if they come here illegally but she
said that people who saw the scenes on
television of the fear and desperation
anguish at kabul airport won't begrudge
afghans being helped to settle in the uk
but of course they're questions about
funding particularly for cash-strapped
local councils having to provide housing
and there really is a question of how
long this is all going to take
for now tomorrow thanks very much
i will let's stick with the story of
how many afghans and others are trying
to get their way out of the country
joining us now on the programme keena
rabbani khan former foreign minister in
pakistan ms carr very good to see you
this morning i i just wonder if we can
start with just the situation on the
border with afghanistan anecdotally we
are hearing that there have been some
issues with people not just getting
across the border but but even getting
to it what kind of influx of of afghans
and others are you seeing at the moment
okay so strangely um
it's very different than what you see on
the tv screens uh the images that you
saw at kabul airport where there seems
to be a rush for people to want to get
out
on the land border uh the one with
pakistan at least you don't see the type
of trucks that we saw post soviet union
for instance withdrawal or as they came
in so it's an ins interesting
juxtaposition for me because on the land
borders the type of numbers that you
have typically seen you may know or
remember that pakistan actually played
host at one point to about four million
afghan refugees in pakistan we currently
are also holding three million afan
refugees in pakistan over the last many
decades so i find it interesting when in
the uk you're talking about numbers as
high as 8 000 uh of afghans who are you
are giving legal rights to stay in
abandon until their sort of future is
determined by the parliament etc so
pakistan is a country has actually
played a lot uh played host to
millions and millions of 500 which is
but right now the situation on the
border is nowhere close to what it has
typically been when it's in influx so it
seems that those people who typically
take the land route are the less
privileged i would say or the ones who
have
are are being threatened by war and by
skirmishes and by being killed so those
people are currently not in large
numbers
yeah
just in terms of your experience of of
the way in which afghanistan and
pakistan have worked together and and
indeed your knowledge of the way in
which the taliban have operated over the
past
you know 20 years what do you make of
their commitments that they are that
they have made uh in terms of safe
passage in terms of continuing the
education of of children and indeed of
of women what what do you make of the
taliban do you think their promises hold
any weight whatsoever
okay so i think we all find ourselves at
a difficult point or
a point where we have no
uh
nothing to guide us in terms of what
should we expect right because we have
the past behavior of the taliban um
which was pre 9 11 pre-2001 in which
girls were not allowed to go to school
uh women were not part of daily upon
life
non-pashtun entities were not really
part of any government
and we now have a completely different
narrative that the taliban are giving to
the rest of the world including pakistan
where they have changed and they are
going to now you know
allow women to have segregated schooling
and perhaps be in
uh government now i i think we all have
to wait and see as to how this is
enacted how this policy statements if
they were a government if you consider
them to be they are in charge of the sun
right now so these are policy statements
which are
future oriented but i think we should
all wait to see how that is translated
into real action and the first big sign
is going to be
what type of government comes into play
and if it is a government which is
generally seen to be representative
where you have some women representation
where you have
a reasonable non-fashion representation
where you have at least
you know some reasonable level of
opposing taliban
entities uh i think we can all expect
better in the future but i i believe uh
i think people are ill place to expect
pakistan to be in any different place
than the rest of the world to know
what's happening because i think we all
are waiting to see how the promises that
they're making or the commitments that
they're making are going to translate
into action
certainly the expectation is that it
will be regional players such as
pakistan that will exert influence that
will exert some pressure uh over the
taliban what what do you make of that in
what way does pakistan do that given the
huge number of refugees as you've
already pointed out
the millions of refugees that have
already
relocated to pakistan
okay so this is the interesting part
because many of the conclusions that
president biden was mentioning in his
speech having saying things like we won
the war 10 years back and we stayed 10
years longer
and we tried to do nation building now
these are all the lessons that pakistan
was telling
um the international community and our
international partners back in 2001 that
let's not go
let's not try and create circumstances
which may not be in the which may not be
reflective of the realities on the
ground and let's take on the project
that we will be able to stay on and see
its fruitation and see it through rather
than run halfway through right so these
are you are absolutely right in saying
that the region and people who are i
would consider the region becomes a
broader region and a smaller region and
a wider region but the immediate region
to me is the immediate neighbors of
afghanistan okay and in that you have
iran you may not like iran but iran is
an immediate neighbor and that runs the
country which has been hosting of one
refugees together with pakistan there's
pakistan of course who has a long forest
which is now fence border this
tajikistan and all the immediate
neighbors of afghanistan i feel have a
better sense
in terms of what uh what is the
likelihood and i also please appreciate
the fact we also have a larger threat
coming in from the instability and the
chaos and the civil war that may
continue in afghanistan so
we are very very scared perhaps much
more scared than anyone else you know
thousands of miles away and oceans and
seas away because we have seen
historically for instability from
afghanistan from terrorism from
afghanistan to permeate through the
border and coming to pakistan and again
i found it interesting when president
biden mentioned american lives lost but
forgot to mention pakistani and most
importantly a fund lives lost in this 20
years adventure which is which runs into
millions of
lives right and as we told by the boston
university uh in the last three years
when the world believes that things were
stable
more afghans were dying afar civilians
were dying through airstrike than in any
year that preceded it so our sense of
stability what we consider to be
stability investing
really uh emanates from uh western lives
it seems and that in itself becomes
problematic not for only people of the
region and afghans but for all of us
collectively because our decision making
is somewhat flawed i believe
indeed hanoi rabbanican i'm very sorry
we do have to leave it there but i think
you got your point across in the last
one certainly very many thanks for
joining us this morning
i want to stay with the story we're
joined now by dr marissa qui uh former
advisor uh to the afghanistan peace and
reintegration program dr cui good to
have you on the program this morning and
as i understand it you you have
colleagues
you have friends and colleagues still in
afghanistan at the moment how are they
getting on what is the situation like
for them
there's i think that there's a lack of
clarity about the number of people who
are left behind operation pitching was
um
was a huge transport of
of a large number of people but there's
still so many left behind especially
vulnerable women
i think there was a lot of lack of
clarity about what the arap program was
and what the bespoke program was
we now need to think about what is going
to happen to them how do we provide
support on the ground
they've been told that they should make
their way by land to borders where they
can get out to to third countries mainly
pakistan for women across a very
perilous landscape that will be a very
dangerous journey there's also the
problem of um the documentation that
they need to cross borders how will that
documentation be
kept safe if they have to show it at
taliban checkpoints what will happen
i know that at the moment there are
explorations about how could it be put
on the cloud how could it be kept safe
um there's also the problem of of money
because the banks have been shut people
have been unable to access their savings
um
that there's a lack of a clear joined up
synthetic response on the part of the uk
the the fcdo could develop a holistic
response that includes food security
experts migration experts regional
experts uh humanitarian experts and
people who are specialists in aid
and and that's the way to move forward
to leverage the human capital
that
migrants constitute they're not a threat
given your involvement in the the the
peace and reintegration program you you
look at what is happening on the ground
in afghanistan you look at where we
started 20 years ago and if you look at
it and you squint it really doesn't
sometimes look that different does it i
mean were those 20 years wasted and if
so who do you blame for that
i think that the hopes of so many people
have been ignited we've kindled a flame
i was asked by
one u.s diplomat why a friend of mine
who was part of the peace program hadn't
applied to migrate to the united states
long before and the reason was because
he's a patriot because he believed in
peace because he believed in democracy
promotion
because he believed in women's rights so
so that those things we have to seek
into
it's not good enough to talk about um
soft power through aid conditionality
and holding the taliban to their word we
have to think about how are we going to
do that in a constructive way and to do
that in a constructive way we have to
leverage the things that mean something
to them and legitimacy on the ground
means something to them so
if if they're interested in a kind of
gender apartheid then you have to say
how are you going to educate female
doctors to supply the needs of women how
are you going to educate female teachers
to supply students um
using interest
rather than universalistic human rights
i just want to ask you just
just before you go what chance is that
the taliban themselves can retain
control of afghanistan we understand of
course any of us are spending time there
knows so any number of disparate groups
tribes
ethnic alliances and the taliban have
come in and have by force you know in
essence taking over
can that persist in the medium term
well isk supposedly has
uh 1500 to 2 200
soldiers on the ground isk is opposed
ideologically to the taliban's collusion
with the west
and the taliban has had trouble uh
controlling isk in the last few days
with the
airport evacuation
there's also the difficulty that
historically afghanistan has been
challenging to govern because of center
periphery differences and because of
factionalism between tribes and clans
the taliban's own factionalism because
it's a heterogeneous rather than a
homogeneous group is going to be
problematic so so there's still a lack
of clarity about whether or not they can
govern
dr marissa quit great to have you on the
program this morning really appreciate
your time
thank you for having me
now the school summer holidays are over
uh well almost for hundreds of thousands
of pupils across england teachers are
using today though to prep for their
return but how are schools going to try
and keep covert free uh our
correspondent shaman freeman powell uh
joins us live from a school in south
london schmann just take us through i
mean it's gonna be a busy busy couple of
days isn't it
it is that's right it is going to be a
busy couple of days i'm at school here
in north village i've just spoken to the
head teacher who said that she is
already going through testing the pupils
they tested year sevens eights and nines
yesterday and expect to test more than
700 pupils by the end of today and this
is of course because pupils are no
longer being asked to wear those face
masks anymore they're no longer being
asked to self-isolate either if they
come into contact with someone that's
tested positive instead they're being
asked to take a pcr test and then
self-isolate if they have a positive
result but not everyone is happy about
this we can remember before in previous
returns that there's a lot of concerns
about the disruption to education
however now some unions are saying that
with less mitigation that tested that
cases sorry could increase but schools
like this one are doing as much as
possible to try and change that shaman
good to see you thanks very much indeed
uh now britain's oldest synagogue
founded well just down the road the
heart of london really is facing an
uncertain future because of plans to
build new skyscrapers immediately next
to it rabbis are concerned that the
building will lose much of its natural
light skies jemima walker went to find
that 17th century building
britain's oldest synagogue has seen 320
years of worship
but modern plans threaten to disrupt
historic traditions
there are proposals for two new office
blocks directly outside bevis marks
one twenty stories high the other 50.
right now it's beautiful with all of the
light and these buildings were
permitted to go forward the light would
be obscured and we'd only have one hour
of daylight a day
rabbi morris believes this could
seriously disrupt worship potentially
even leading to the closure of the
synagogue
light is incredibly important for jewish
prayer
reading from the prayer book and it's
also the
spiritual experience of when light kind
of enters into the space and you feel
that that lift
i think the reality is that if a
50-story tower was proposed next to st
paul's
it would be a non-starter
and we're asking that bevis is also
afforded some level of protection
ten generations of chris musicant's
family have married at bevis marks
it's a tradition she wants to continue
i find it exceedingly painful to think
that because of some developments
it might cease to be a living entity it
isn't a museum it is actually a living
very vibrant entity
a city of london corporation
spokesperson said
the city of london corporation's
planning and transportation committee
considers all relevant planning matters
including relevant representations both
for and against development before
taking a final decision on planning
applications the city of london is an
economic generator for the nation
high-rise buildings can play a role in
driving that
people like chris hope development won't
leave this historic synagogue in the
dark
jeremiah walker sky news london
china has introduced a new law limiting
the amount of time teenagers can play
video games all part of an effort to
curb addiction here to tell us more
about it a technology journalist will
guy well good to see you um and at the
core of these proposals you know a limit
of one hour a day judging by the
machines over your shoulders when you
were under 18s that wouldn't have been
something you'd have been able to cope
with
oh no definitely not and the thing
that's really interesting me about this
is this is china essentially attempting
to put the genie back in the bottle if
we tried something like this in the uk
there would be protests on the street
i'm really interested to see how this
progresses and how this pans out whether
china develops a golden generation of
geniuses who've got all of their social
issues and problems solved
many
many countries don't believe that video
games are quite as devious as china is
suggesting uh chinese state media called
video games a few weeks ago um spiritual
opium which is probably one of the
largest disses i've ever heard for the
video games industry in the 20 plus
years i've been covering it i'm just i'm
just hugely interested to see how this
develops nobody can argue that video
games have an influence over people's
lives whether it's destructive or
enhancing it's still in some people's
eyes up for discussion
we've had cases from
universities here in the western world
and in europe saying the actual benefits
of video games are incredibly positive
but as an experiment looking at china as
a petri dish for doing something like
this um i i'm really intrigued to see
what the results will be like and
whether or not they can actually hold
kids to this because
a number of uh gamers in china already
use what's called a virtual private
network these are the services you can
get which means you can essentially
pretend your computer is anywhere in the
world and thus circumvent any of the
systems they may be putting in place so
this could potentially be a bit of a tit
for tap between chinese teenage gamers
and uh and and the state and also it
looks like the state has developed some
teeth on this they said they're going to
be regularly checking what kids are
doing and they're also going to penalize
games companies if they do so well what
kind of size of a market then is are we
potentially going to be losing out on
here
well 46 billion us dollars this year
alone was the predictions for chinese
video gaming so this is not a drop in
the ocean and this has waves across the
world because china has invested
massively in western culture western
video gaming companies companies in the
in england in scotland in wales all over
the last few years and if this is the
chinese state essentially telling these
companies to back out of video gaming
and adjust to a way of life that they
prefer you have to wonder whether those
investments are safe long term some of
the biggest video games companies in the
western world saw share prices dented
the other day when this was announced
they've recovered slightly since then
but there has to be some
nervousness in those companies when
they've taken tens of millions of pounds
from
investment from chinese companies who
may no longer be allowed to to be in the
video game space well quite quickly if
you can i mean you mentioned vpns there
you know and obviously kids could you
know get their parents to log in for
them as well i mean did the chinese not
have just slightly more control though
over their internet than perhaps other
countries in the west that might
interfere here
virtual private networks definitely
still work in china i speak to a number
of people in china who use them perhaps
the most interesting thing here is that
they're suggesting that they're going to
use real id so gamers have to use their
real name and real identification which
if possible is going to be very
interesting for companies like twitter
and others in the uk well we're going to
have to let you get back to your gaming
because we're just about out of time
very good to see and i'm coming around
to have a go on that one over your right
shoulder very very soon